what does Jungian psychology have to do
in religion everything everything
you see Young has demonstrated that the
religious function resides in the psyche
and is a integral part of human
psychology and that just means that the
that the ego in order to be healthy
needs to have a living connection to a
transpersonal center that's there are
two etymologies for the word religion
one etymology emphasizes that it means
linking back the idea then would be that
the that the religious function links
the ego back to its to its origin to its
background to the to the larger entity
that it came from the the other
etymology of religion that Jung really
preferred actually was that the that the
word the word read religio means the
opposite of the root of the word neglect
so that religio means the careful
consideration of the background of one's
life the opposite of neglecting the
background of one's life and Jung
actually preferred that Association
although he acknowledged the importance
of the other one in which I think goes
back to Augustine but the point is that
the human psyche has a religious
function in both sentences
I need to link back and a need to give
careful careful consideration to the the
the source of his being and the
religious process then is is one in
which the ego has a living organic
connection to a larger hole and that of
course is the function that the
traditional religions have always served
they've they've done it by by the the
collective structure and the dogmatic
formulations and they're the whole
concept of God and man's relation to God
that they provide the believer they've
they've given given the individually a
religious container in which he has the
sense of being connected to the larger
whole now modern man especially those
the the creative minority of modern man
has lost that that connection provided
by the traditional religions because
they're took concrete they they haven't
they haven't kept pace with with modern
man's mental mental development so
they're not they're not in tune with
modern categories of understanding so
the great service that Jung has
performed has by by his discovery of the
of the collective unconscious and the
and the archetypes and the and the self
he's he's penetrated to the
psychological source and basis that
underlies all the world religions and
thereby he's verified and redeemed for
modern consciousness the validity and
reality of the religious operations as
as they
express themselves in all religions
that's been achieved and I don't think
we can appreciate the the magnitude of
that achievement because what it means
is that the psychological basis has been
laid for the realization of a unified
world we've got the basis now for a
unification of all the factual divisions
among the world religions and once that
achieved is achieved I think political
unification is bound to follow it's been
accomplished one man has done it I wish
I could communicate the fact that I and
I see so so clearly concerning Jung's
discovery of the of the basis of all the
world's religions he's achieved by this
discovery the psychological basis for
the unification of the world it's really
as a pitiful sight to see the the world
split up into these separate warring
fragments of religious identifications
of nationalistic identifications of
ethnic identifications all all that war
with one another they're they're all
operating out of the energies of
connection with the same with the same
transpersonal
image of wholeness they are all
operating out of their connection to to
deity to the self as it is concentrated
and perceived within their their their
local context religious or nationalistic
context it's the same it's the same
psychic itself and what Jung has done as
has penetrated to to that source that's
the paradoxical God that he talks that
he talked about he's seen it and once
he's seen it it it can then no longer
split up into these these various ethnic
and and religious factions and fight
against itself one human being has seen
the the back of God so to speak so that
means then that he's going to be
eventually unified and the the world
will be unified politically sooner or
later as a as an inevitable consequence
of that that event of human
consciousness